You are not Robin of Locksley anymore.
You are Robin Hood.
You were a Lord.
But now you get to be a thief.
And I am going to show you how.
Shoot me.
Please.
You have to be a warrior.
As fast as you can.
Faster.
What are you doing to my coat?
Again.
When do I actually get to you know steal?
What else you got?
There's been whispers
of a thief.
I am the law and order here.
Any talk of the thief, bring it to me.
One thing keeps him in power.
The money, we steal it. Wanna hit the treasury itself.
Setup a meeting.
Everyone is with us.
This is our shot.
Here is the plan.
This is an inside job. You are the lord.
Get closer to sheriff. Who do you think deceive this?
Clearly he is well trained.
Adaptable under fire.
You'll get him eventually.
Our plan is working.
Now we see you right.
I'll remind them they are not the people, they are my subjects.
This is  suicide.
Can't you see what you are doing?
You inspire the people.
A thousand pounds
for the man who brings me Hood.
We are all suspects now.
If we get caught they will kill us all.
Really inspiring, thanks.
You are not Robin of Locksley anymore.
You are Robin Hood.